[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui j'ai fait péter la
veste je vous explique pourquoi tout à
l'heure récemment je me suis aperçu que
j'avais pas fait de true story depuis le
2 décembre de l'année dernière sur cette
chaîne c'est beaucoup trop long
donc aujourd'hui je me suis dit que
j'allais vous expliquer comment j'ai
fait pour avoir un job dont je ne
voulais pas et dont je n'avais
clairement pas le profil au départ
génériques
[Musique]
alors oui j'ai mis une petite baisse
puisque ce soir je suis en première
partie de pierre cros série ma petite
dame quand je suis sur scène je fais un
effort en parlant de scène si vous
voulez me voir un spectacle qui reste
plus que six villes rouen nice champéry
en suisse
conflans sainte honorine et moret sur
loing c'est près de paris et nantes où
je jouerai pour la dernière si vous êtes
dans ce secteur-là venez c'est la grosse
fraise vous le dis parce qu'après on
verra plus sur scène avant un moment
l'anecdote que je vais vous raconter
elle remonte à 2006 il ya onze ans c'est
pas gentil de me faire prendre
conscience comme ça à quel point je
vieillis déjà je sais que mes poils
blancs me le rappelle à cette époque là
je m'étais pris la tête avec une pote ce
qu'ils cherchaient du travail et
j'estime et qu'elle ne prenez pas la
bonne méthodologie pour n'avoir elle
était prête à faire n'importe quel
travail en attendant pour en avoir et
pour la motiver je vais proposer qu'on
passe un entretien d'embauché pour une
société qui a la rochelle et qui est
dans vous savez dans tout ce qui est
téléphonie en fait que ce soit pour
vendre des trucs genre d assurance des
choses comme ça ou aussi pour faire du
sav je crois qu'à l'époque il faisait le
sav de 9.9 vous connaissez peut-être
plus le 9 mai avant il y avait le neuf
c'était très gênant parce que je suis
phobique un peu de ce chiffre
donc on s'inscrit l'un et l'autre pour
faire chacun le cursus est là motif que
je le fasse en même temps qu'elle et
puis un côté un petit peu challenge mais
moi je fais vraiment ça pour le motiver
je ne cherche pas de travail à cette
époque les tumeurs je me dis j'ai pas du
tout les références et les diplômes qui
demande pour le poste donc j'y vais les
mains dans les poches
mais le problème c'est que pour moi la
vie c'est un jeu et dès qu'ils en
challenge j'ai envie de jouer de gagner
un peu comme un puzzle qui vaudraient
résoudre et ça se passe en deux étapes
la première étape on était un groupe de
quinze ou vingt je me suis un peu
exactement autour d'une grande table
iodé battait au départ autour d'un thème
et puis après il y avait une espèce de
jeu de rôle les règles étaient les
suivantes jeu devait en fait être comme
un vendeur par téléphone avec un
objectif de vendre quelque chose de
précis et le rck auteurs se mettait dans
le rôle du client celui mais vous savez
celui qu'on fait chier en fait le
téléphone car a demandé et koech a donné
son numéro de fixe un jour dans un
magasin et donc on a revendu à une
société bon lui incarner cette personne
là et le thème sais que je dois vendre
des bûches de bois compressé donc des
petites bûches combes et de la cheminée
mais ce que je savais pas c'est que
recruteur avant d'être recruteurs c'est
un vendeur et pour lui il est au top du
top de sa tête
et là il va se mettre à jouer le client
chiens potentiellement avec non c'est
moi j'étais en train de vendre quelque
chose que je ne maîtrisais pas et que je
connaissais pas je n'ai aucune info sur
le produit donc c'était un gros battle à
chaque fois qu'ils me donnaient un
contre argument comme quoi il était pas
intéressé je trouvais un meilleur contre
arguments sont contre arguments en
utilisant toujours une logique
implacable et jeu
hanks halle lagaf' je vois que celle-là
casque durant les quinze vingts
personnes qui a 2 présente je sois
capable en fait de mettre un petit peu à
mal en fait
épris d'énervement je le voyais rougir
avec les narines qui commençait à se
dilater donc on n'était pas loin de la
colère quand même mais de toute manière
ça m'intéresse pas j'ai pas de cheminée
là je suis toi mon gars tu me tend une
perche magnifique
alors j'ai changé mon fusil d'épaulé et
là je dis à vous n'avez pas de cheminée
écoutez monsieur je tiens à vous
adresser les excuses de la part de notre
société
quelqu'un on a moins mal fait les fiches
et nous étions pas censé vous appelez
puisque vous n'avez pas ce besoin
potentiel donc encore une fois excusez
moi de vous avoir dérangé et nous allons
supprimer votre numéro des listes s'il
met cas pas de cheminée on n'était pas
sans celle appelée à la barre dans un
fichier clients bref ça l'agacé mais
l'observateur donc il y avait un
recruteur et un observateur je pense que
ça lui a plu puisque je suis passé en
dernière étape et de la dernière étape
c'était un recrutement en individuel
dans un bureau donc on faisait tout cela
que en fait on attendait ce qu'avait été
sélectionné un petit peu mais on avait 5
à 10 minutes d'entretien après dont
bureau où j'étais assise dans une espèce
de salles d'attentes avec d'autres
personnes et quand je m'ennuie un peu
j'ai pris la brochure de la société la
brochure elle faisait de mémoire entre
50 et 70 pages sais je sais c'est large
mais je me suis appuyé exactement ce que
je me souviens par contre c'est que je
me suis amusé à apprendre chaque page
alors non pas par coeur et en entier
mais d'apprendre le thème principal de
chaque phrase
les images clés les valeurs clés qui
était mise en avant j'ai utilisé tout
bêtement une table de rappel pour ça
comme j'ai déjà pu vous expliquer sur la
playlist mémoire j'ai été reçu en
entretien qui était une sorte de
discussion jeu ponctué toute mes
réponses de vingtenaires comme vous
l'expliqué dans la page 23 il faut
d'abord améliorer la relation clientèle
ça a été ça durant cinq dix minutes ce
qui est hyper bleus font pour la
personne en face parce qu'elle a
l'impression que tu connais tous ligne
darling alors que ce n'était pas vrai
mais c'était déjà pas mal d'avoir retenu
tous les thèmes généraux de chaque page
et j'essayais justement le de replacer
la finalité de tout ça c'est qu'on m'a
rappelé pour m'offrir le job que j'ai
refusé parce que vraiment je ne voulais
pas faire ce travail là je voulais pas
aller faire ça chez eux en plus j'avais
pas besoin de travailler j'étais pas
tout à fait d'accord avec ce système de
fonctionnement est par contre quel
chouette c'est que ma pote adultes afpa
ce qui lui a permis d'avoir du travail
sur un certain temps ce n'était pas
vraiment s'il voulait faire mais en
attendant de trouver mieux c'était très
bien alors pourquoi je vous raconte tout
ça va déjà parce que vous m'aviez
demandé une nouvelle true story et les
story c'est le seul truc on se met des
défis de like et ça fait un petit moment
que celle du 2 décembre à passer
largement le quota qu'on s'était donné
pour les stories mais un défi de la
ligue y perd au c'est volontaire c'est
pas forcément du light pour du light
c'est aussi pour qu'ils n'aient pas trop
fréquemment sur la chaîne y en avait que
4 l'année dernière sur 366 vidéo donc la
prochain quotas il sera disons 10 % des
abonnés quoi on va dire 40000 à 40000 je
reprenne story donc ce sera peut-être
dans très longtemps alors j'ai aussi
choisi cette anecdote parce que je la
trouve marrant tu si vous voulez j'avais
pas forcément les compétences pour avoir
ce taf la demande d'utiliser deux
techniques de mentalist en fait une sur
l'argumentation rationnelle et une sur
la table de rappel qui sont des choses
très simples que je vous ai expliqué sur
la chaîne est bien juste avec ses deux
choses là on peut essayer de choper un
job et ça répond aussi un peu à la
question de ça sert à quoi le mentaliste
dans le quotidien bien voilà ça peut
servir à ça n'oubliez pas et je veux
dire très très vite les dernières villes
rouen nice champéry confiance at
honorine moret sur loing à nantes pour
les dernières dates du spectacle bien
dans la description le livre qui sort le
18 mai liens dans la description pour le
précommander je suis dans une de ces
phases de reconnaissance où j'avais
envie de vous dire merci des piats les
464 1750
merci n'oubliez pas de vous abonner un
petit pouce en l'air et à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]